well now look there's plenty of
derangement to go around these days in
Hollywood Donald Trump's Walk of Fame
star has become a consistent vandalism
target there is with the pickaxe on
MSNBC never Trump Republican Rick Wilson
became so worked up about Trump
he began cursing and a channel had to
kill his audio feed there's a bigger
never Trump movement out there there's
just a huge courage deficit in this
country because of my past failures and
of course it happens every day we had to
implement a seven-second to that so what
you said will probably not make it out
there yeah that's probably the best way
that's probably the best way to listen
to Rick Wilson knows with silence
well someone you do want to hear from
who I know well and I enjoy her
commentary Kathy aru is the founding
publisher of Catalina magazine and this
shows liberal Sherpa and we say that
with all kinds of appreciation she joins
us now in studio Kathy how you doing
good how are you good I've enjoyed being
on as a guest with you and so it's a
pleasure to be to be sitting across from
you now look you've seen everything
we've seen you heard Larry right you
know Rosie O'Donnell you get some
attention she's a performer right she
used to be a comedian I don't laugh when
I hear from her anymore
it's not what these lines know well yeah
so would you agree I mean is this is
this helpful for the entertainment
industry and for liberals in general
it's been you know almost a year and a
half isn't it time to just say okay
let's find what we have in common or is
it all still too early with Rosie
O'Donnell mean this war has been going
on for 12 years it's personal it's
really personal when he was asked to
call women pigs during the debates he
said only Rosie O'Donnell
I mean it's truly personal and then he
became president so this person you've
had a war with for 12 years becomes
president so she's out there she's not
so funny anymore because she's so angry
but you know if you go to Caroline's
maybe she's hysterical but reality stars
are in Congress now there's one in the
White House so entertainment politics is
mixing but when you say though
that that when it comes to their
business that Donald Trump's having a
better time than Rosie O'Donnell is or
really anyone in Hollywood at this point
right now the American Way it's a First
Amendment I mean they had the right
digit sure and Donald Trump was out
there he had the apprentice but he was
still fighting with the birther movement
yeah so he did both he juggled both do
you think his star now you know West
Hollywood just voted not that they have
a vote right but they voted to to demand
the removal effectively if Donald
Trump's star on the Hollywood Walk of
Fame do you think it should stay there
do you think it should go well he paid
for it just like everyone else they
might not know that they don't know that
he did pay for that star nobody does
everyone does you you you buy this
section you know it's it's not like
awarded to you and it's free money
everybody on the on the Walk of Fame
pays for it so he paid for that star
that it is start he rightfully paid for
it but if it is becoming a problem if
it's dangerous if people are hurting one
another over that star maybe this little
a should be removed maybe they need to
remove the people to prison
yeah the police need to right yeah I
mean that's not right no one should it
should ban de life anything like that
that's his star he earned it any paid
for it now look you're you've got a
really great attitude you're not letting
the circumstances which you don't like
ruin their life look she's laughing it's
a liberal is laughing we have great
conversations right that don't make us
miserable right isn't it wouldn't you
say that we've or maybe you think it
needs to continue the current liberal
attitude of all rage all the time
especially from Hollywood do you think
that that's worn out by now or do you
think that's really the thing that that
liberals in Hollywood should be doing is
the continual perpetual outrage I don't
think it's all of them though we can't
say all of Hollywood we can't say
everyone that's the whole point I'm a
liberal and I'm not I'm not losing my
mind that's I think that's true group
just with the GOP I think both sides
have extremes and both extremes are
losing their mind all right well there
you go except for us we are not alright
that thank you can do incre Sherpa best
fabulous stuff